Життя в безпеці - ось чого хотіли Дмитро та Христина Горенюк для своєї доньки Дани.
Вони виїхали з України ще 24 лютого - буквально через кілька годин після початку повномасштабного вторгнення Росії.
Христина була на той момент вагітна.
У Німеччині народилася їхня донька Дана.
Маленькій українці всього декілька місяців.
Батьки радіють, що народження дитини в іншій країні пройшло без ускладнень.
Ми коли сюди приїхали, одразу почали думати, де народжувати.
Всі, кого ми питали, казали нам, що треба народжувати вдома.
Чим далі ми проходили цей процес, тим далі ми розуміли, що в принципі це нормально.
Бо тут такий догляд за тобою, що в процесі тобі можуть сказати, чи можеш ти народжувати вдома чи ні.
Всі походи до лікаря були дуже швидкими.
Ніяких проблем не виникало.
І коли вже підійшов момент пологів, ми просто знайшли лікарню.
Подружжя вважає, що їм дуже пощастило виїхати разом,
адже більшість українських біженців у Німеччині - це жінки, чоловіки яких залишилися в Україні.
Молода сім’я потроху освоїлася в новій країні - знайшли житло, вчать німецьку,
а також намагаються призвичаїтися до того, як все влаштовано в новій для них країні.
Я знаю німецьку мову зі школи. Я її забула, звичайно, тому що не практикувала.
І як тільки ми ступили на цей шлях, я зрозуміла, що потрібно її згадувати.
У нас тут живуть друзі, які не знають взагалі німецької, і їм нормально.
Але як тільки ти стикаєшся з державними органами, то це дуже складно, бо ніхто не розмовляє англійською.
І навіть DHL чи Ikea і якісь такі установи - краще знати німецьку, бо якщо щось станеться, то все.
Одна з причин виїзду саме до Берліна - це можливість швидко знайти роботу.
І Дмитро, і Христина вже її знайшли. Дмитро - за професією дизайнер і арт-директор.
Христина працює в рекламі, а ще вона співачка, відома в Україні під сценічним ім’ям Lucy.
Вона навіть виступала тут, у Німеччині, будучи вагітною.
Але окрім роботи, є і інші причини, чому пара обрала сама Берлін.
Тут багато знайомих насправді. Дуже багато знайомих і друзів, які тут живуть і можуть допомогти нам,
і ми можемо з ними побачитися. Тут дуже велике українське ком’юніті, багато культурних діячів і дизайнерів.
Саме наявність родичів, друзів чи знайомих, а також високий рівень захисту прав людини у Німеччині
стали основними причинами вибору цієї країни для більшості українських утікачів від війни.
Про це свідчать дані першого великого звіту про українських біженців,
який представили у Німеччині після 10 місяців повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну.
У дослідженні взяли участь понад 11 тисяч українських біженців.
80 відсотків з усіх дорослих учасників опитування - жінки, майже половина з них приїхали до ФРН з дітьми.
Ми були дуже здивовані нашими результатами.
Насправді ми виявили, що лише дев’ять відсотків біженців живуть у так званому груповому житлі,
а всі інші - у приватному секторі, з родичами чи друзями, яких вони вже знали.
Але переважна більшість із тих, хто проживає в приватних помешканнях, справді мають власну квартиру.
Таким чином вони змогли знайти квартири, куди вони змогли переїхати,
що дійсно дуже й дуже сприяє інтеграції цих сімей.
Із початком повномасштабної війни РФ проти України Німеччина прийняла близько мільйона українців.
Це більше, ніж будь-яка інша країна Європейського Союзу, за винятком Польщі.
Середній вік українських біженців у Німеччині - 28 років.
Це молодше, ніж загалом населення і України, і Німеччини.
Рівень освіти у них - значно вищий за середній. Приблизно 18 відсотків українських біженців
після півроку вже знайшли собі роботу в Німеччині, і з кожним місяцем їх стає дедалі більше.
Ця частка значно вища, ніж серед біженців з інших країн.
Суперництва з місцевими кадрами на німецькому ринку праці експерти не очікують.
Навпаки, за їхніми словами, українські біженці допомагають пом'якшити дефіцит робочих рук, що зростає в Німеччині.
При цьому добре німецьку мову знають лише 4 відсотки опитаних, 80 відсотків - погано чи зовсім ніяк.
Але половина всіх українців справно відвідує мовні курси, третина ще й інтеграційні.
Українські біженці в Німеччині користуються тими самими соціальними благами, що й німці.
Приблизно 60 відсотків із них живуть на державну допомогу, і соціальне відомство оплачує їхнє житло.
При цьому рівень задоволеності життям серед українців у Німеччині відносно низький.
За шкалою від 0 - що означає "загалом незадоволений" - до 10 - що означає "повністю задоволений" -
маємо середнє значення у лише 5,8 у порівнянні з показником у 7,8 для решти населення, що живе в Німеччині.
Тож ми бачимо, що війна та втеча від неї залишили сліди, які відчутно і далі.
На питання "чи планують українці повертатися в Україну" 37 відсотків опитаних відповіли,
що хотіли б залишитися в Німеччині або назавжди, або принаймні на кілька наступних років.
34 відсотки біженців планують залишатися у ФРН лише до закінчення війни.
І тільки 2% утікачів від війни планують повернутись до України впродовж року.
Христина з Дмитром належать до тих, хто ще не визначився.
Ми просто чекаємо остаточної перемоги, тому що повернутися назад нам поки неможливо.
Але ми переживаємо за майбутнє нашої дитини. Зараз це центр нашого життя.
Молоде подружжя зізнається, що якби не донечка, мабуть, вже повернулися б додому.
Утім, наразі безпека Дани для них - на першому місці.